THE NEWS AND
AARON RODGERS KNOCK TIM TEBOW
OFF THE TOP OF THE STACK THE
AFTERNOON THAT THE DRAFT
BEGAN. THANKFULLY THAT WAS
THE LAST THING THAT ANYONE
WANTED TO DO WAS DELVE INTO
THE POSSIBILITY. OF A GUY
WHO'S BEEN OUT OF THE NFL FOR
NEARLY A DECADE COMING BACK
IS SOME SORT OF A GIMMICK
WITH THE JAGUARS WILL NOW,
NOW THAT THE JAGUARS ARE IN
THIS WEIRD HOLDING PATTERN OF
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT, WE'RE
DO IT. WE'RE GOING TO DO IT.
WE JUST HAVEN'T DONE IT YET.
AARON RODGERS OFF THE TOP
STACK AT LEAST FOR A LITTLE
WHILE AND WE'RE GOING TO TALK
SOME MORE ABOUT TEBOW BECAUSE
IT REALLY IS IMMINENT. LET'S
LET'S NOT TAKE MY WORD FOR IT
AS IF ANYONE EVER WOULD TAKE
MY WORD FOR ANYTHING. HERE'S
URBAN MEYER, COACH OF THE
JAGUARS TALKING TO CHRIS
COLLINSWORTH ON THE CRIS
COLLINSWORTH PODCAST, ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THE JAGUARS
WILL BE SIGNING, TIM TEBOW.
HERE IT IS.
YEAH, WE HAVE NOT SIGNED TO
HIM. THERE'S A THOUGHT GO
AROUND, YOU KNOW, HE, HE WAS
IN THE BEST SHAPE OF HIS LIFE,
ASK TO SEE IF HE CAN WORK
OUT WITH A COUPLE OF OUR
COACHES. I WASN'T EVEN THERE
AND THEY CAME BACK TO ME AND
SAID, WOW, THIS GUY'S IN
INCREDIBLE SHAPE. AND I SAID
BEN I WENT ANOTHER TIME AND
WATCHED HIM, TRY THEM OUT AND
THEY SHOULD GO WORK ON THESE
THINGS. HE COMES BACK LATER.
TRY THEM OUT AGAIN. I'M NOT
THERE, THEY COME IN AND SAID
WOW YOU KNOW, THIS GUY'S
NOT WANT WHATEVER HE IS 33
AND I SAID GUYS, YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND NOW, THIS GUY IS
HE'S THE MOST COMPETITIVE
MANIAC. YOU EVER GOING TO
TALK TO AND LET'S GIVE IT A
SHOT AND I HAVE NOT DECIDED
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT OR
NOT YET. I'M GETTING CLOSE. I
GOT TO MAKE A DECISION HERE
PRETTY SOON.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE CERTAIN
PEOPLE I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
PLAY POKER WITH IN THE NFL. I
THINK OUR URBAN MEYER IS ONE
OF THEM. LET'S GIVE IT A
SHOT. WELL, WE HAVEN'T
DECIDED TO DO IT YET. LET'S
GIVE IT A SHOT. WE'RE NOT.
WAIT WAIT WELL LET'S GIVE IT
SHOT ONCE HE SAYS LET'S GIVE
IT A SHOT ONCE HE SAYS, LET'S
GIVE IT A SHOT. IT'S OVER THE
STUFF. YOU SAY AFTERWARDS,
DOESN'T MATTER. LET'S GIVE
IT A SHOT. WELL, WE HAVEN'T
DONE IT YET. WE HAVEN'T DONE
IT YET, BUT I JUST SAID,
LET'S GIVE IT A SHOT. SO
WE'VE JUST LIKE WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT TREVOR LAWRENCE TO
PETER KING WEEKS AGO. IT WAS
CLEAR. THEY WERE GOING TO
DRIVE TREVOR LAWRENCE, AND HE
STOPPED SHORT OF SAYING,
WE'RE GOING TO DRIVE TREVOR
LAWRENCE, BUT IT WAS CLEAR
FROM THE CONTEXT AND THE
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
THIS IS JUST SOME SORT OF A
INTO A HOT BATH THAT WE CAN
ALL KIND OF GET USED TO IT.
IT'S TAKEN A COUPLE OF WEEKS,
YOU KNOW, FOR IT TO REALLY
COME OUT AND MAYBE THIS IS
AIMED AT PEOPLE IN THE
ORGANIZATION THAT MAY NOT BE
THRILLED WITH IT. I DON'T
KNOW WHY. THIS IS TAKING SO
LONG, THEY WORKED HIM OUT
THREE TIMES. IF MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT MYERS
SAID IS ACCURATE, THREE TIMES,
AT LEAST THEY WORKED HIM OUT,
SO I FEEL LIKE IT'S COMING.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF WHEN,
MEAN ME TOO. I MEAN I MEAN,
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, FIRST OFF
URBAN MEYER HE
CHERISHES TIM TEBOW. HE DOES.
COULD SEE HIM JUST THERE IN
THAT LITTLE CONVERSATION WITH
CHRIS COLLINSWORTH. I MEAN,
JUST THE LOOK ON HIS FACE,
THINGS HE SAYS, YOU KNOW,
HE'S GONNA, YOU KNOW, WORK
HARDER THAN ANY HUMAN YOU'VE
EVER SEEN BEFORE AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. LISTEN,
URBAN MEYER HAS BEEN A BIG
BELIEVER IN TIM TEBOW FROM
THE COLLEGE DAYS. I MEAN,
THAT'S AND THAT'S WHERE, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, THAT'S WHERE I
THINK IT RUBS SOME PEOPLE
WRONG HERE. YOU KNOW, I THINK
AT THE BASE LEVEL, I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH FOOTBALL VALUE
TIM TEBOW HAS ON THE FOOTBALL
FIELD.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW. AND OF
COURSE, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
CAN DO AS A TIGHT END. HE'S
DONE IT BEFORE AND HE HAS, OH
YES. OH, I KNOW THAT ONE
SLAY, THAT WOVEN OVER AND
OVER. YES, GREAT ROUTE. YES.
OFF HIS HEAD BALL SKILLS.
YES. RIGHT. SO OKAY. BUT NOW
I MEAN HEY IT'S MORE JUST
LOOKING MORE THAN ANYTHING
AND I THINK WHAT BOTHERS SOME
PEOPLE IS JUST AN OLD COACH
DOING A GUY A FAVOR IN LIKE
HEY YEAH BUDDY I'LL GIVE YOU
TWENTY SEVEN STRIKES TO FAIL
IN SPORTS. DON'T
YOU JUST KEEP COMING BACK AND
I THINK THAT'S WHERE IT
BOTHERS A LOT OF ATHLETES
PLAYERS. PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
WHERE THEY JUST DON'T FEEL
LIKE THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES SO MUCH. AND,
BUT, BUT THIS IS A RARE
SCENARIO, WHERE A COACH IS
REALLY BOUGHT INTO ONE GUY. I
WENT BACK AND FOUND THE STORY
WE WROTE IT PFFT WHEN TIM
TEBOW RETIRED, FROM A
BASEBALL CAREER THAT DIDN'T
QUITE MAKE IT TO THE MAJOR
LEAGUES. ALTHOUGH THE METS
DID EVERYTHING THEY COULD TO
PUSH IT THERE FOR
FINANCIAL REASONS, FINE, FIND
THEIR PREROGATIVE, IT'S AN
ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS, MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE. YOU WANT
TO PUT A GUY ON THE FIELD,
WHO REALLY SHOULDN'T BE THERE
BECAUSE YOU CAN SELL A BUNCH
OF HIS JERSEYS AND PEOPLE
COME TO THE GAMES. GOOD, WE
GOT A HUNDRED SIXTY TWO GAMES.
SHE GOT TO GET PEOPLE TO
SHOW UP, BUT WHEN HE RETIRED
FROM BASEBALL, I SPECULATED
HE WAS GOING TO END UP IN
JACKSONVILLE, NOT AS A PLAYER.
I NEVER DREAMED. IT WOULD BE
AS A PLAYER. I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE AS A COACH BRING HIM
INTO SOME SORT OF ASSISTANT
TO THE ASSISTANT TO THE
AND BECAUSE OF THAT CRONYISM,
WE SEE A LOT OF NEPOTISM IN
FOOTBALL, THERE'S PLENTY OF
CRONYISM TO TAKING CARE OF
FRIENDS. HAVING GUYS AROUND
THAT, YOU CAN TRUST, GUYS.
KNOW, GUYS YOU WANT TO HELP
GUYS? YOU LIKE GUYS, YOU
CHOOSE TO SPEND THE TIME.
IT'S A STRETCH THOUGH. CHRIS
IS A BIG STRETCH TO MAKE HIM
A FLIER? YES BIG STRETCH LIKE
YOUR THAT'S THE WET. YOU'RE
RIGHT. THAT'S PART OF LIFE.
THAT'S PART OF BUSINESSES,
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. THAT'S
OKAY. IF YOU'VE GOT
HISTORY WITH THE
IN THE NFL AND HE'S PLAYED.
MAYBE RECENTLY IN THE NFL TO
GO ALONG WITH THAT. OKAY,
OKAY, MAYBE IT'S OKAY FOR THE
COACHES. HEY, THAT'S UNDER
THE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PLAYERS ARE GOING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT PLIERS
ARE NOT GOING TO UNDERSTAND
THIS. THAT'S WHERE IT'S A
STRETCH TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
GO WAIT THERE'S PLENTY OF
THERE'S FREE AGENT TIGHT ENDS
OUT THERE. THERE'S OTHER GUYS
IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL WHO
WEREN'T DRAFTED AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT YOU COULD
MAKE THE MOVES AND DO THOSE
THAT'S WHERE IT'S A BAD, LOOK.
A TOTAL STRETCH FROM THAT
STANDPOINT. YOU KNOW THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO MERIT TO THE
SIGNING AND IT MAKES NO SENSE.
THIS IS NOT ALDON SMITH.
I'VE SAT OUT FOR FIVE YEARS
AND OH WAIT THAT'S RIGHT. I
WAS ONE OF THE BEST EDGE PASS
RUSHERS IN FOOTBALL AND I'M
NOT CHANGING POSITIONS. I'M
COMING BACK TO PLAY THE SAME
POSITION. I WAS DOMINANT AT
BEFORE THE NFL AND I HAD MY
ISSUES. THIS IS NOWHERE NEAR
THAT, THAT'S WHERE IT'S CRAZY.
IT'S CRAZY.
EVIL. AND THAT'S WHERE I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT. I DON'T,
I DON'T THINK IT'S A GOOD
LOOK FOR URBAN MEYER OR THE
JAGS REALLY, JEFF, DARLINGTON.
AND ESPN SAID YESTERDAY, NOT
EVERYONE IN THE JAGUARS
BUILDING IS THRILLED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL. TIM TEBOW
ARRIVAL. THAT'S A POINT CHRIS
YOU MADE YESTERDAY. HOW DO
YOU SELL THIS IN THE LOCKER
ROOM? HOW DO YOU GET THE
OTHER PLAYERS TO ACCEPT
WITHOUT THE SIDE EYE OR THE I
ROLL OR ANY OTHER FACIAL
EXPRESSION OR BODILY
GESTURE? THAT WOULD SUGGEST
WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU DOING
OUCH, HOW DO YOU PULL THAT
OFF? AND I THINK THIS IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A GUY
WHO'S NEVER COACHED AT THE
NFL LEVEL IN ANY CAPACITY,
MAKING THE ADJUSTMENT ON THE
FLY. YOU CAN'T BRING THE, I'M
THE EMPEROR OF THE COLLEGE
FOOTBALL PROGRAM. I'LL DO
WHAT I WANT. YEAH, IT'S NOT
GONNA WORK TO AN NFL LOCKER
ROOM. IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK. YOU
DON'T LORD OVER NFL PLAYERS.
THE WAY THAT YOU LORD, OVER
COLLEGE PLAYERS. AND IF AN
NFL PLAYER HAS AN ISSUE,
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. HE'S GONNA
TALK TO HIS BUDDY ABOUT IT
AND THEY'RE GOING TO TALK TO
THEIR BUDDY ABOUT IT AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AN ISSUE
IN YOUR LOCKER ROOM THAT YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
BECAUSE IT COLUMBUS AND
GAINESVILLE EVERY OTHER STOP
WHERE URBAN MEYER'S BEEN. HE
CAN NIP IT IN THE BUD PRETTY
QUICKLY, BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
SCARED CRAPLESS OF HIM. YEAH,
I MEAN, HE'S BEEN THE
DICTATOR. HE'S BEEN LIKE YOU
SAID, THE THE GOD ON CAMPUS
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. IT
IS DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW, MAYBE
YOU COULD HAVE GOT AWAY WITH
THE NFL RIGHT? BUT IT'S JUST
A DIFFERENT PLAYER ALL
TOGETHER IN THE LEAGUE. SO, I,
KNOW, AGAIN, WE DON'T HEAR
LIKE THOSE GENERALS WHO ARE,
YOU KNOW, ALWAYS YELLING
ORDERS AND GET YOUR TOES ON
THE LINE AND ALL THAT THAT
COACH DOESN'T REALLY EXIST
ANYMORE IN THE NFL. THAT'S
NON-EXISTENT. WE SAW THAT A
LITTLE LIKE, RIGHT WITH A
GREG, SHE ANNA, AND SOME OF
THAT WAS THE KELLEN WINSLOW
CHANT, RIGHT? GREG SHANNO,
TOES ON THE LINE. YEAH,
EXACTLY. IT DOESN'T WORK
AGAINST GROWN MEN. EXACTLY.
A DISASTER. WE SAW THE LAST
GUY. WE REALLY
SAW WITH IT. IS TOM COUGHLIN
MAY BE RIGHT, WHOO, HE EVEN
HAD TO GO, LIKE, WAIT, I
CAN'T BE THE GENERAL. I'D
LIKE TO BE I GOT TO LIKE BOUT
OF THE PLAYERS A LITTLE BIT
AND CHANGE HERE. IT'S 2007-8,
WHATEVER. SO YEAH, DON'T WAIT,
HE REMOVE THE PATCHES FROM
HIS SHIRT WHEN HE DECIDED TO
NO LONGER BE THE GENERAL? YOU
PROBABLY DID. HE HUNG UP HIS
MEDALS IN THE CLOSET FOR A
LITTLE WHILE. IT SAID I'LL BE
BACK IN A LITTLE WHILE AFTER
THIS BUT YEAH, URBAN MEYER'S
GOTTA GOTTA BE CAREFUL OF
SO THAT'S THAT'S GOING TO BE
ONE OF THESE MOVES RIGHT NOW
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE,
HEY I'M THE KING. I LIKE THIS
GUY AND I WANT TO GIVE
HIM ANOTHER CHANCE. AND OF
COURSE, THE PLAYERS ARE GOING
TO ACCEPT IT BECAUSE HE IS
THE KING, BUT IT IS GOING TO
THEM LOOK OUT OF THE SIDE
EYE AND GO LIKE, MAN, WHY ARE
WE DOING FAVORS FOR THIS GUY?
WHAT DID HE DO TO DESERVE TO
BE HERE? WHY IS HE TAKING MY
REPS RIGHT NOW DURING SEVEN
ON SEVEN? I MEAN, THERE'S ALL
THOSE TYPE OF ISSUES AND
THAT'S WHAT URBAN MEYER'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT AND POLITICAL
ONE THING I STRUGGLED WITH
YESTERDAY WAS THE OBVIOUS.
KAEPERNICK COMPARISON. YEAH.
AND THE QUICK KNEE-JERK. WAIT
MINUTE AND WE TALKED ABOUT IT,
THE STRONGEST ARGUMENT
AGAINST KAEPERNICK NOW, IS HE
HASN'T PLAYED IN THE NFL IN
FOUR YEARS? WELL, THIS GUY
EIGHT SEASONS. 2013 THROUGH
HASN'T PLAYED IN THE NFL IN
2020. NO. REGULAR-SEASON
EIGHT SEASONS. 2013 THROUGH
FOR TIM TEBOW SO IT BLOWS OUT
2020. NO. REGULAR-SEASON
OF THE WATER. THE IDEA THAT
FOR TIM TEBOW SO IT BLOWS OUT
WELL IT'S BEEN FOUR YEARS NOW
OF THE WATER. THE IDEA THAT
OCCURRED TO ME YESTERDAY
WELL IT'S BEEN FOUR YEARS NOW
AFTERNOON. THERE IS ONE
OCCURRED TO ME YESTERDAY
COMMON THREAD BETWEEN TEBOW
AFTERNOON. THERE IS ONE
AND KAEPERNICK. URBAN MEYER
COMMON THREAD BETWEEN TEBOW
IS THE ONLY COACH THAT WOULD
AND KAEPERNICK. URBAN MEYER
HAVE EVER SIGNED TIM TEBOW.
IS THE ONLY COACH THAT WOULD
THERE'S NO LAND RUSH FOR THE
HAVE EVER SIGNED TIM TEBOW.
THREE BOAT, RIGHT? THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO LAND RUSH FOR THE
BUZZ THAT IT'S MAKING ITS WAY
THREE BOAT, RIGHT? THERE'S NO
THROUGH 32 NFL FRONT OFFICES.
BUZZ THAT IT'S MAKING ITS WAY
HEY, DID YOU HEAR TIM TEBOW'S
THROUGH 32 NFL FRONT OFFICES.
IN THE GREATEST SHAPE OF HIS
HEY, DID YOU HEAR TIM TEBOW'S
LIFE? DID YOU HEAR? HE HAD
IN THE GREATEST SHAPE OF HIS
THREE AWESOME WORKOUTS
LIFE? DID YOU HEAR? HE HAD
INJECTION SHOULD WE CALL TIM?
THREE AWESOME WORKOUTS
TIM TEBOW SHOULD DO. WE
INJECTION SHOULD WE CALL TIM?
WE BRING TIM.
TIM TEBOW SHOULD DO. WE
ABOUT KNOW. NOBODY CARES.
WE BRING TIM.
NOBODY ELSE IS GOING TO TOUCH
ABOUT KNOW. NOBODY CARES.
TIM TEBOW EVER. THERE'S ONE
NOBODY ELSE IS GOING TO TOUCH
MAN IN THE WORLD WHO WOULD
TIM TEBOW EVER. THERE'S ONE
SIGN TIM TEBOW AND THAT MAN
MAN IN THE WORLD WHO WOULD
IS NOW THE HEAD COACH OF THE
SIGN TIM TEBOW AND THAT MAN
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS AND I
IS NOW THE HEAD COACH OF THE
SAY THAT BECAUSE I THINK
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS AND I
THERE'S ONE GUY IN THE WORLD.
SAY THAT BECAUSE I THINK
WOULD SIGN COLIN KAEPERNICK
THERE'S ONE GUY IN THE WORLD.
AND THAT GUY IS YOUR FRIEND
WOULD SIGN COLIN KAEPERNICK
AND MINE, JIM HARBAUGH. YEAH,
AND THAT GUY IS YOUR FRIEND
YOUR HEAD COACH AT MICHIGAN,
AND MINE, JIM HARBAUGH. YEAH,
HE'D GOTTEN THE JACKSONVILLE
YOUR HEAD COACH AT MICHIGAN,
YOUR HEAD COACH AT MICHIGAN
HE'D GOTTEN THE JACKSONVILLE
IF HE'D GOTTEN THE
YOUR HEAD COACH AT MICHIGAN
JACKSONVILLE JOB, HE'S
IF HE'D GOTTEN THE
SIGNING TIM TEBOW. NOW MAYBE
JACKSONVILLE JOB, HE'S
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN SOME
SIGNING TIM TEBOW. NOW MAYBE
PUSHBACK INTERNALLY MAY BE
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN SOME
ON WOULD HAVE SAID, YOU KNOW,
PUSHBACK INTERNALLY MAY BE
WE'RE RUNNING A BUSINESS HERE.
ON WOULD HAVE SAID, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE TRYING NOT TO SCARE
WE'RE RUNNING A BUSINESS HERE.
FANS AWAY. WE WANT TO LURE
WE'RE TRYING NOT TO SCARE
THEM TO COME TO THE GAMES BUT
FANS AWAY. WE WANT TO LURE
HARBAUGH IS THE ONE GUY WHO
THEM TO COME TO THE GAMES BUT
HAS CONSISTENTLY SPOKEN OUT
HARBAUGH IS THE ONE GUY WHO
IN FAVOR OF KAEPERNICK BACK.
HAS CONSISTENTLY SPOKEN OUT
WHEN ALL THIS STARTED, HE WAS
IN FAVOR OF KAEPERNICK BACK.
ON THIS PROGRAM YOU SIGNED
WHEN ALL THIS STARTED, HE WAS
COLIN KAEPERNICK YOU WILL WIN
ON THIS PROGRAM YOU SIGNED
CHAMPIONSHIPS WITH AN S ON
COLIN KAEPERNICK YOU WILL WIN
THE END. SO THE
CHAMPIONSHIPS WITH AN S ON
EASY EXPLANATION IS WHY
THE END. SO THE
TEBOW AND WHY NOT KAEPERNICK?
EASY EXPLANATION IS WHY
BECAUSE URBAN MEYER'S THE
TEBOW AND WHY NOT KAEPERNICK?
COACH OF THE JAGUARS NOT JIM
BECAUSE URBAN MEYER'S THE
HARPER I MEAN THAT'S IT. I
COACH OF THE JAGUARS NOT JIM
MEAN WE SAID THAT YESTERDAY
HARPER I MEAN THAT'S IT. I
THAT'S WHERE I MEAN, YOU
MEAN WE SAID THAT YESTERDAY
SENSE FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
THAT'S WHERE I MEAN, YOU
FOOTBALL AND WHAT HE CAN DO
SENSE FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
FROM YOU ON THE FIELD BUT IT
FOOTBALL AND WHAT HE CAN DO
MAKES SENSE IN A WHOLE LOT OF
FROM YOU ON THE FIELD BUT IT
OTHER WAYS. AND WE TALKED
MAKES SENSE IN A WHOLE LOT OF
ABOUT THE BUSINESS ASPECT OF
OTHER WAYS. AND WE TALKED
IT IN JACKSONVILLE, YOU KNOW,
ABOUT THE BUSINESS ASPECT OF
I FEEL LIKE THE SHOT CONNIE
IT IN JACKSONVILLE, YOU KNOW,
EVEN HIM COMING OUT LAST WEEK,
I FEEL LIKE THE SHOT CONNIE
RECOGNIZING THIS CONVERSATION.
EVEN HIM COMING OUT LAST WEEK,
THAT WAS ANOTHER STEP INTO
RECOGNIZING THIS CONVERSATION.
LIKE, HEY, LET'S GAUGE THE
THAT WAS ANOTHER STEP INTO
TEMPERATURE AND MAKE
LIKE, HEY, LET'S GAUGE THE
EVERYBODY FEEL COMFORTABLE
TEMPERATURE AND MAKE
THAT THIS IS COMING TO YOUR
EVERYBODY FEEL COMFORTABLE
POINT AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT THIS IS COMING TO YOUR
THAT. SO. BUT BUT THAT AND
POINT AND EVERYTHING LIKE
HEY, THE WORLD AND THE NFL,
THAT. SO. BUT BUT THAT AND
WELL, ESPECIALLY, I MEAN IT'S
HEY, THE WORLD AND THE NFL,
BECOME MORE OF LIKE NOT IT'S
WELL, ESPECIALLY, I MEAN IT'S
NOT WHAT YOU KNOW IT'S WHO
BECOME MORE OF LIKE NOT IT'S
YOU KNOW AND THAT'S ALL
NOT WHAT YOU KNOW IT'S WHO
THROUGH THE RANKS AND THAT'S
YOU KNOW AND THAT'S ALL
ALL THROUGH THE RANKS. AND
THROUGH THE RANKS AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT PART OF THE
ALL THROUGH THE RANKS. AND
PROBLEMS. WE HAVE THE ISSUES
THAT'S WHAT PART OF THE
AND, YOU KNOW, THE COLLEGE
PROBLEMS. WE HAVE THE ISSUES
AND I MEAN IN THE COACHING
AND, YOU KNOW, THE COLLEGE
RANKS AS FAR AS LACK OF
AND I MEAN IN THE COACHING
DIVERSITY AND THINGS LIKE
RANKS AS FAR AS LACK OF
THAT. IT'S BECAUSE, HEY, I
DIVERSITY AND THINGS LIKE
THIS GUY I WANT TO WORK WITH
THAT. IT'S BECAUSE, HEY, I
HIM, I WANT TO DO THIS, I
THIS GUY I WANT TO WORK WITH
WORKED WITH THEM, YOU KNOW, I
HIM, I WANT TO DO THIS, I
TRUST HIM. LIKE YOU SAID ALL
WORKED WITH THEM, YOU KNOW, I
OF THOSE TYPE OF THINGS. SO
TRUST HIM. LIKE YOU SAID ALL
TEBOW IS GETTING THE BENEFIT
OF THOSE TYPE OF THINGS. SO
OF THE DOUBT BECAUSE HE'S
TEBOW IS GETTING THE BENEFIT
FROM THE AREA. HE IS A
OF THE DOUBT BECAUSE HE'S
GOD-LIKE FIGURE DOWN
FROM THE AREA. HE IS A
AREA.
GOD-LIKE FIGURE DOWN
YEAH, AND YOU'RE RIGHT. THE
AREA.
MAIN THING IS, HE HAS A COACH
YEAH, AND YOU'RE RIGHT. THE
WHO THINKS HE'S THE GREATEST
MAIN THING IS, HE HAS A COACH
THING SINCE SLICED BREAD. I
WHO THINKS HE'S THE GREATEST
MEAN, HE TREATS THEM LIKE
THING SINCE SLICED BREAD. I
IT'S A SON, YOU KNOW, AN
MEAN, HE TREATS THEM LIKE
EXTENSION OF HIS FAMILY AND I
IT'S A SON, YOU KNOW, AN
THINK THAT'S JUST TOO HARD
EXTENSION OF HIS FAMILY AND I
FOR URBAN MEYER TO LIKE, KIND
THINK THAT'S JUST TOO HARD
CLOSE THE DOOR ON THAT. I
FOR URBAN MEYER TO LIKE, KIND
THINK HE'S GOT A PIECE OF HIS
CLOSE THE DOOR ON THAT. I
DOOR ON THAT. I THINK HE'S
THINK HE'S GOT A PIECE OF HIS
GOT A PIECE OF HIS HEART THAT
DOOR ON THAT. I THINK HE'S
BELONGS AT TIM TEBOW AND
GOT A PIECE OF HIS HEART THAT
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING TO SEE
BELONGS AT TIM TEBOW AND
HIM THERE. AND THERE IS A
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING TO SEE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE BEYOND
HIM THERE. AND THERE IS A
THE FACT THAT HE'S NOT A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE BEYOND
MEMBER OF HIS FAMILY, URBAN
THE FACT THAT HE'S NOT A
MEYER DOESN'T OWN, THE TEAM
MEMBER OF HIS FAMILY, URBAN
THAT IS THE FIREWALL. THAT
MEYER DOESN'T OWN, THE TEAM
NFL FRANCHISE IS WHEN YOU OWN
THAT IS THE FIREWALL. THAT
THE TEAM AND YOU ARE GOING TO
NFL FRANCHISE IS WHEN YOU OWN
EVENTUALLY AGE AND DIE AND
THE TEAM AND YOU ARE GOING TO
YOU HAVE CHILDREN, YOU GROOM
EVENTUALLY AGE AND DIE AND
YOUR CHILDREN TO TAKE OVER
YOU HAVE CHILDREN, YOU GROOM
THE BUSINESS. OTHERWISE
YOUR CHILDREN TO TAKE OVER
THEY'RE GOING TO SELL IT AND
THE BUSINESS. OTHERWISE
THERE IT GOES. IT'S GONE.
THEY'RE GOING TO SELL IT AND
WHEN YOU'RE THE COACH. THAT
THERE IT GOES. IT'S GONE.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S A
WHEN YOU'RE THE COACH. THAT
BLANK CHECK TO HIRE ANYONE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S A
YOU WANT WITHOUT REGARD TO
BLANK CHECK TO HIRE ANYONE
MERIT, WE HEAR ALL THE TIME.
YOU WANT WITHOUT REGARD TO
FOOTBALL IS A MERITOCRACY AND
MERIT, WE HEAR ALL THE TIME.
CHRIS I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU,
FOOTBALL IS A MERITOCRACY AND
IT'S NOT WORSE. NOW, WHEN IT
CHRIS I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU,
COMES TO NEPOTISM AND
IT'S NOT WORSE. NOW, WHEN IT
CRONYISM, I THINK WE'VE
COMES TO NEPOTISM AND
EVOLVED TO THE POINT WHERE
CRONYISM, I THINK WE'VE
WE'RE SENSITIVE TO IT,
EVOLVED TO THE POINT WHERE
THESE FOUR OTHERS BASED ON
WE'RE SENSITIVE TO IT,
MARA. YEAH, SIMPLE, RIGHT.
THESE FOUR OTHERS BASED ON
I'M HIRING MY KID TO BE THE
MARA. YEAH, SIMPLE, RIGHT.
ASSISTANT STRENGTH COACH WAS
I'M HIRING MY KID TO BE THE
YOUR KID. THE BEST CHOICE. I
ASSISTANT STRENGTH COACH WAS
DON'T CARE. IT'S MY KID. I'M
YOUR KID. THE BEST CHOICE. I
HIRING MY FRIEND TO BE THE
DON'T CARE. IT'S MY KID. I'M
ASSISTANT QUARTERBACKS COACH.
HIRING MY FRIEND TO BE THE
I'M GIVEN THE QUALITY CONTROL
ASSISTANT QUARTERBACKS COACH.
JOB TO MY NEPHEW YOU KNOW,
I'M GIVEN THE QUALITY CONTROL
ARE THINGS THAT TURN THE IDEA
JOB TO MY NEPHEW YOU KNOW,
OF MERIT ON ITS HEAD. YES,
ARE THINGS THAT TURN THE IDEA
TEBOW IS THE PLAYER
OF MERIT ON ITS HEAD. YES,
EQUIVALENT OF THAT, YOU'RE
TEBOW IS THE PLAYER
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT. THE CHRONY,
EQUIVALENT OF THAT, YOU'RE
WHILE THE ADOPTED SON,
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT. THE CHRONY,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY,
WHILE THE ADOPTED SON,
THIS IS A GUY WHO DOESN'T
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY,
HAVE THE SKILL TO PLAY IN THE
THIS IS A GUY WHO DOESN'T
NFL, BUT HE'S GOING TO BE
HAVE THE SKILL TO PLAY IN THE
PLAYING IN THE NFL OR AT
NFL, BUT HE'S GOING TO BE
LEAST HE'S GOING TO BE AN NFL
PLAYING IN THE NFL OR AT
ROSTER. AND AND AND YOU KNOW,
LEAST HE'S GOING TO BE AN NFL
I SAW SOME TWEETS YESTERDAY
ROSTER. AND AND AND YOU KNOW,
THAT BASICALLY HEY, YOU KNOW,
I SAW SOME TWEETS YESTERDAY
THAT BASICALLY HEY YOU KNOW
THEY DO CRAZY THINGS FROM
TIME TO TIME. GEORGE PLIMPTON.
ONCE PLAYED QUARTERBACK FOR
THE LIONS FOR A BOOK, HE WAS
WRITING, WHATEVER THE CASE
WAS, YOU HAVE A RIGHT, BUT
CALL HIM A GIMMICK, IT'S A
GIMMICK. YEAH, GIMMICKS
HAPPENED RIGHT. THIS IS A
GIMMICK. THIS ISN'T REAL.
WE'RE BEING LED
I BELIEVE IT'S REAL WHEN YOU
SEE URBAN MEYER,
EXPLAIN TO CRITICIZE, HE'S
GREAT, HE'S GOT GREAT BALL
SKILLS EXCEPT FOR THAT ONE
PLAY. WHEN YOU PLAYED TIGHT
END, PAY NO ATTENTION TO THAT
PLAY, PLEASE BUT OTHERWISE
TRUST ME, HE'S GREAT. HE'S
READY. DON'T SELL ME ON IT
BEING A MERITOCRACY COACH,
WHEN IT'S A GIMMICK. JUST
JUST ADMIT THAT. IT'S A
GIMMICK BECAUSE IT IS IT'S A
GIMMICK CHRIS. I MEAN, IT'S
YES, TO ALL OF US BUT IS IT A
GIMMICK TO TO, YOU KNOW, TO
URBAN, MEYER LOT TO HIM? TIM
TEBOW? NO, IT'S NOT THEM. I'M
IT IS TURBINE.
IF I MEAN URBAN MEYER EITHER,
I THINK HE LOOKS AT THE GUY
LIKE, YOU KNOW, I THINK IF HE
SITS THERE AND HE WANTS TO
MOVE THEM OUT AND HE CAN, HE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO MOVE THAT
MOUNTAIN. I THINK HE LOOKS A
TEAM TEAM TEAM. TIM TEBOW
LIKE THAT HE DOES MAYBE
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT'S COACHED
IN THE NFL SINCE 2012 IS
WRONG, MAYBE EVERYONE ELSE
HAS GOTTEN IT WRONG. THEY
HAVE MISSED THIS DIAMOND IN
THE ROUGH AND TONIO GATES IN
TRAINING. THEY COULD HAVE HAD
AND THEY COULD HAVE HAD THE
ORIGINAL KELLEN WINSLOW.
WHOA, THEY COULD HAVE HAD
TONY GONZALEZ AND THEY ALL
MISSED OUT BECAUSE THEY ALL
DIDN'T HAVE THE FORESIGHT TO
HAVE THIS GUY SHOW UP, RUN
ROUTES AND DEMONSTRATE THAT
HE'S IN THE GREATEST SHAPE OF
HIS LIFE. ISN'T IT? FUNNY
ANY TIME ANYONE HAS EVER IN
ANY SHAPE, THEY'RE IN THE
GREATEST SHAPE OF THEIR LIFE
COURSE, AT SOME POINT. YOU
YOU, YOU CAN'T CONTINUOUSLY
BE IN THE GREATEST SHAPE OF
YOUR LIFE AT SOME POINT. IT
IS GOING. WELL, THAT'S
ANOTHER THING TOO WEIRD, DOG.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
ATHLETE WHO RAN FOR SEVEN OF
THE COMBINE AND HAS NOT
PLAYED FOOTBALL AT EIGHT.
YEARS. I MEAN DO WE THINK
IT'S PEOPLE THINK HE'S GOING
TO BE FASTER? HE'S GONNA BE
FASTER THAN WHEN HE CAME OUT
OF COLLEGE. OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
NO, HE WON'T. YOU KNOW. AND
I TH
THAT'S LIKE I WAS, I
TEXTING WITH AN EX-TEAMMATE,
YOU KNOW, THE YESTERDAY AND
CAME UP JUST REAL QUICK,
RIGHT? BUT I THINK HE BROUGHT
UP A GOOD POINT. AND THE FACT
THAT BASICALLY SAYING LIKE,
YOU KNOW, THE GUY HAD A THE
LEAGUE, WANTED THEM TO MOVE
TO TIGHT END AND DO THOSE
A CHANCE THERE. AND HE SAID
NO NO NO, NO, NO TO THE POINT
WHERE HE QUIT THE SPORT
BECAUSE HE WOULDN'T DO IT.
AND THEN HE COMES BACK
BECAUSE WHAT? NOW HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO BASEBALL,
DIDN'T WORK. SO NOW I'LL
CHANGE AND I'LL COME BACK,
YOU KNOW, AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT SAY IT OR NOT PLAYERS
MIGHT SAY IT, THEY MIGHT NOT,
I DON'T KNOW, BUT THAT'S
GONNA PISS PLAYERS OFF
BECAUSE NOBODY IS GIVEN THAT
CHANCE NOBODY ALMOST IN THE
HISTORY OF FOOTBALL HAS BEEN
RIGHT NOW, 2021 AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON IN
THE WORLD. SORRY THAT'S PART
OF THE CONVERSATION HERE AND
IT JUST HAS A BAD LOOK ON THE
OPTICS BECAUSE OF THAT THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT I CAME BUT I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A VALID
POINT THERE TO BUY AN
EX-TEAMMATE WHO I DON'T WANT
TO PUT ON BLAST, BUT I THINK
IT DOES RUB SOME PEOPLE THE
WRONG WAY AS FAR, ESPECIALLY
EX-FOOTBALL PLAYERS AND
CURRENT FOOTBALL AND COLONEL.
THAT'S RIGHT. WRONG WAY,
THERE IS A CONSTANT CHURNING
OF GUYS AT THE BOTTOM OF A
ROSTER, TRYING TO GET ON A
BUSTING THEIR ASSES NEVER
CHECKED OUT. NEVER WENT AND
PLAYED SOME OTHER SPORT, AND
BACK TO FOOTBALL. AND AND NOW
JUST EXPECTS TO SHOW UP AND
BE GIVING PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT BY HIS FORMER
COLLEGE COACH IN THE WEHMEYER
EXPLAINED IT. IF YOU WERE
PAYING ATTENTION CLOSELY TO
WHAT HE SAID EARLIER IN THE
CLIP, WE PLAYED TEBOW REACHED
OUT TO THEM, I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT I CHOOSE TO
BELIEVE THAT SINCE IT IS A
GIMMICK AND THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE US THINK IT'S NOT A
GIMMICK. SO, I RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO
BS ON
ANY ASPECT OF WHAT'S SAID
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THE WHOLE
THING IS CODED IN BS, BUT
SORRY ALL DUE RESPECT, WE'RE
HERE TO SHOOT THE WORLD OF
HIS MUCH BS AS WE CAN. YEAH,
YEAH, THERE'S THERE'S
REASON FOR PEOPLE TO BE
RESENTFUL WITHIN THE JAGUARS
ORGANIZATION. THERE'S REASON
FOR OTHER PLAYERS TO BE
RESENTFUL. THE DEVON BUSH
TWEET THAT WE MENTIONED
EARLIER. I MEAN, DEVON BUSH.
HE'S THE ONE THAT POINTED OUT
YESTERDAY. TEBOW GOT A JOB
BEFORE KAEPERNICK, WAIT TILL
WE.
WE PLAY JACKSONVILLE. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THESE ARE SUPPOSED
TO MEAN. I'LL LEAVE IT TO THE
EYE OF THE BEHOLDER TO
INTERPRET AND THEN DEVON BUSH
GOT UPSET BECAUSE BLEACHER
REPORT, YOU KNOW, MENTIONED
THAT HE SAID WHAT HE SAID. I
ALWAYS LOVE IT. WHEN, WHAT
THE HELL IS UP WITH THAT
LATELY? PEOPLE IN THE NFL,
THEY SAY SOMETHING FOR
ATTENTION, WE GIVE THEM
ATTENTION AND THEN THEY GET
MAD BECAUSE WE GAVE THEM
ATTENTION. IT'S THE HEY
EVERYBODY. LOOK AT ME. WHAT
THE HELL ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
IT'S THE MINDSET, IT'S WEIRD.
I DON'T KNOW. IT'S A IT'S A
THING WITH OUR SOCIETY RIGHT
NOW. LIKE, THE HELL WAS
SPORTS. IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE GOING DOWN THE HIGHWAY
RIGHT NOW AND IF SOMEBODY THE
PERSON IN FRONT OF YOU IS
DRIVING DOWN THE MIDDLE OF
THE LANE ON BOTH LANES,
RIGHT, RIGHT GRAND, THE WHITE
LINE AND TEXTING, AND YOU
PULL UP TO THEM AND GIVE THEM
THE FINGER AND WITH AND
THEY'RE MAD AT YOU. THEY'RE
LIKE, HOW DARE YOU CALL? I
MEAN, IT'S A COMMON THING
RIGHT NOW. FAIR DARE, YA. HOW
DARE YOU CALL ME OUT FOR
BREAKING THE LAW AND LOOKING
AT MY INSTAGRAM? WHY I'M
DRIVING 90 WHAT A JERK YOU
YOU ARE JUST LET ME JUST MAKE
A GENERAL OBSERVATION. YEAH.
AND TO BE A STUDENT OF THE
HUMAN CONDITION, RIGHT? WHEN
YOU GIVE SOMEONE THE FINGER,
RIGHT, WHATEVER THE CONTEXT,
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO PRECEDE,
THE GIVING OF THE FINGER
PRECEDE THE GIVING OF THE
FINGER CHANCES ARE THE
REACTIONS, NOT GOING TO BE A
PAUSE. WELL, THAT'S JUST WELL,
YOU'RE RIGHT. BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT? I FEEL LIKE A REAL GOOD
HUMAN WHO MIGHT BE DOING THAT
AND ON INSTAGRAM DRIVING
BETWEEN TWO LANES AND THEN
SOMEBODY LIKE HONKED AND GAVE
HIM THE FINGER. LIKE, DUDE,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING? I'D BE
LIKE, MAN, YOU'RE RIGHT, I'M
SORRY. WHAT THE HELL AM
I DOING?
A LITTLE WAVE AND LIKE, GET
BACK ON MY TWO HANDS ON THE
STEERING WHEEL. BUT NO DID.
IS THIS ACTUALLY GIVE THE
FINGER DID ONE OF US ACTUALLY
GIVE THE FINGER. OH, DOING
THAT I'M APPLEHEADS. I DON'T
KNOW. I THINK I STUCK UP. I
THINK I DID THIS. I THINK I
STUCK UP. I THINK I DID THIS.
I THINK I DID THAT. I DON'T
THINK I DID THIS. I THINK I
DID THAT. I DON'T THINK I
I THINK I DID THAT. I DON'T
HAVE. NO, NO, OKAY, GOOD,
DID THAT. I DON'T THINK I
GOOD, JUST WE'RE SELLING. I
HAVE. NO, NO, OKAY, GOOD,
WAS NERVOUS THERE FOR A SEC.
GOOD, JUST WE'RE SELLING. I
I DIDN'T YOU BECAUSE ONCE YOU
WAS NERVOUS THERE FOR A SEC.
START DEMONSTRATE, I KNOW
I DIDN'T YOU BECAUSE ONCE YOU
TALK WITH YOUR HANDS. YOU
START DEMONSTRATE, I KNOW
TALK ABOUT GIVING THE FINGER,
TALK WITH YOUR HANDS. YOU
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW. KNOW, I
TALK ABOUT GIVING THE FINGER,
WASN'T SURE. YOU'RE RIGHT,
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW. KNOW, I
AND YOU SAID IT, BUT IT WAS
WASN'T SURE. YOU'RE RIGHT,
LIKE, OH NO. MAYBE I DID. BUT
AND YOU SAID IT, BUT IT WAS
DIDN'T MEAN, BUT I DIDN'T MEAN
LIKE, OH NO. MAYBE I DID. BUT
, BUT I DIDN'T MEAN TO CHANGE
DIDN'T MEAN, BUT I DIDN'T MEAN
THE SUBJECT.
, BUT I DIDN'T MEAN TO CHANGE
EJECT. BUT YES, COME ON.
THE SUBJECT.
DEVON BUSH. LIKE WHAT DO YOU
EJECT. BUT YES, COME ON.
THINK? YOU'RE THE MIDDLE
DEVON BUSH. LIKE WHAT DO YOU
LINEBACKER FROM MICHIGAN.
THINK? YOU'RE THE MIDDLE
YOU'RE A FIRST ROUND PICK
LINEBACKER FROM MICHIGAN.
FROM PITTSBURGH. LIKE WE'RE
YOU'RE A FIRST ROUND PICK
GOING TO LOOK AT YOUR
FROM PITTSBURGH. LIKE WE'RE
INSTAGRAM. WE'RE ALL LOOKING.
GOING TO LOOK AT YOUR
DON'T HAVE AN INSTAGRAM, THEN
INSTAGRAM. WE'RE ALL LOOKING.
IF YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
DON'T HAVE AN INSTAGRAM, THEN
PAY ATTENTION TO IT, THAT
IF YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
MAKES NO SENSE. I DON'T
PAY ATTENTION TO IT, THAT
UNDERSTAND THAT EITHER MIKE,
MAKES NO SENSE. I DON'T
LET'S ADDRESS SOME OF THE
UNDERSTAND THAT EITHER MIKE,
NARRATIVE BACK. DOORS,
LET'S ADDRESS SOME OF THE
YESTERDAY ON TWITTER, PETE
NARRATIVE BACK. DOORS,
HAS COLLECTED, SOME OF THEM,
YESTERDAY ON TWITTER, PETE
BELL. HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT
HAS COLLECTED, SOME OF THEM,
TEBOW? DOESN'T DESERVE THE
BELL. HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT
JOB. WHEN YOU DIDN'T SEE HIS
TEBOW? DOESN'T DESERVE THE
WORK OUT, WHAT JOSHUA BELL
JOB. WHEN YOU DIDN'T SEE HIS
SAID IS, YOU HAVEN'T SEEN HIS
WORK OUT, WHAT JOSHUA BELL
WORK OUT, YOU'RE PROBABLY.
SAID IS, YOU HAVEN'T SEEN HIS
SAY, HE DOESN'T DESERVE
WORK OUT, YOU'RE PROBABLY.
ANYTHING FOR ALL. WE KNOW
SAY, HE DOESN'T DESERVE
HE DID FOR ALL WE KNOW HE
ANYTHING FOR ALL. WE KNOW
RAN A 4/5 FOR ALL. WE KNOW.
HE DID FOR ALL WE KNOW HE
CHASED THAT CHICKEN AND HE
RAN A 4/5 FOR ALL. WE KNOW.
CAUGHT IT FOR ALL. WE KNOW
CHASED THAT CHICKEN AND HE
HE'S GOING TO EAT LIGHTNING
CAUGHT IT FOR ALL. WE KNOW
AND HE'S GONNA CRAP THUNDER
HE'S GOING TO EAT LIGHTNING
BUT I THINK WE'RE ALLOWED TO
AND HE'S GONNA CRAP THUNDER
APPLY COMMON SENSE AND LOGIC
BUT I THINK WE'RE ALLOWED TO
TO THIS AND SAY THIS ISN'T
APPLY COMMON SENSE AND LOGIC
SOME MAGICAL ALIGNING OF
TO THIS AND SAY THIS ISN'T
METAPHYSICAL FORCES THAT ALL
SOME MAGICAL ALIGNING OF
OF A SUDDEN HAVE TURNED THIS
METAPHYSICAL FORCES THAT ALL
GUY INTO A TIGHT END. YES,
OF A SUDDEN HAVE TURNED THIS
EXACTLY. THIS IS SOMEONE
GUY INTO A TIGHT END. YES,
DOING A FAVOR FOR A BUDDY,
EXACTLY. THIS IS SOMEONE
RIGHT RE IT, AND COPY SENSE,
DOING A FAVOR FOR A BUDDY,
AND HE'S AND JOSHUA BELL.
RIGHT RE IT, AND COPY SENSE,
HE'S NEVER PLAYED THE
AND HE'S AND JOSHUA BELL.
POSITION BEFORE OTHER THAN
HE'S NEVER PLAYED THE
ONE PLAY LIKE THIS. SO I DON'T
POSITION BEFORE OTHER THAN
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE YOU
ONE PLAY LIKE THIS. SO I DON'T
WANT TO SAY THEY'RE LIKE OKAY
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE YOU
YEAH, THE WORKOUT LOOK GOOD.
WANT TO SAY THEY'RE LIKE OKAY
GREAT, LIKE LISTEN, LIKE NO
YEAH, THE WORKOUT LOOK GOOD.
DISRESPECT, BUT, YOU KNOW,
GREAT, LIKE LISTEN, LIKE NO
YOU IF YOU GIVE ME A MONTH,
DISRESPECT, BUT, YOU KNOW,
YOU GIVE ELI MANNING A MONTH.
YOU IF YOU GIVE ME A MONTH,
ALRIGHT? AND JUST SAY HEY
YOU GIVE ELI MANNING A MONTH.
LET'S TRAIN AND WORK ON JUST
ALRIGHT? AND JUST SAY HEY
RUNNING TIGHT END ROUTES AND
LET'S TRAIN AND WORK ON JUST
THINGS LIKE THAT. WE DON'T
RUNNING TIGHT END ROUTES AND
HAVE TO BLOCK ANYBODY OVER.
THINGS LIKE THAT. WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO IS GO RUN AROUND
HAVE TO BLOCK ANYBODY OVER.
AND CATCH THE BALL. WE'RE
HAVE TO DO IS GO RUN AROUND
GOING TO LOOK PRETTY GOOD IN
AND CATCH THE BALL. WE'RE
ALL WHAT THAT MEANS, NOTHING,
GOING TO LOOK PRETTY GOOD IN
IS, WE KNOW, HE'S IN, HE'S IN
ALL WHAT THAT MEANS, NOTHING,
IN SHAPE ATHLETE. HE'S NOT
IS, WE KNOW, HE'S IN, HE'S IN
LIKE SOME FOOL. I GET THAT
IN SHAPE ATHLETE. HE'S NOT
BUT THAT MEANS NOTHING TO ME.
LIKE SOME FOOL. I GET THAT
THE FACT THAT HE WAS IN
BUT THAT MEANS NOTHING TO ME.
SHAPE FOR A WORKOUT AND TRUST
THE FACT THAT HE WAS IN
ME, IT DIDN'T BLOW ANYBODY
SHAPE FOR A WORKOUT AND TRUST
OUT OF THE WATER TO THAT
ME, IT DIDN'T BLOW ANYBODY
EXTENT. URBAN CAN SAY ALL HE
OUT OF THE WATER TO THAT
WANTS TO CRIS COLLINSWORTH IF
EXTENT. URBAN CAN SAY ALL HE
IT BLEW HIM OUT OF THE WATER
WANTS TO CRIS COLLINSWORTH IF
TO THAT EXTENT. LIKE
IT BLEW HIM OUT OF THE WATER
PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE, THEY
TO THAT EXTENT. LIKE
WOULD HAVE PROBABLY CALLED
PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE, THEY
OTHER COACHES AROUND THE
WOULD HAVE PROBABLY CALLED
LEAGUE AND SAID SOMETHING AND
OTHER COACHES AROUND THE
THEN YOU WOULD HAVE MAYBE
LEAGUE AND SAID SOMETHING AND
BOATRIGHT LIKE COME ON.
THEN YOU WOULD HAVE MAYBE
THAT'S AN INSANE. YOU SAW
BOATRIGHT LIKE COME ON.
THAT DAY IF HE BLOWS YOU OUT
THAT'S AN INSANE. YOU SAW
OF THE WATER, YOU SIGNING
THAT DAY IF HE BLOWS YOU OUT
THAT DAY BECAUSE ACTUALLY WE
OF THE WATER, YOU SIGNING
DON'T HAVE THREE WORKOUTS,
THAT DAY BECAUSE ACTUALLY WE
EXACTLY. WE'VE GOT A NEW AND
DON'T HAVE THREE WORKOUTS,
IMPROVED, TIM TEBOW, NOT
EXACTLY. WE'VE GOT A NEW AND
ONLY IS HE IN THE GREATEST
IMPROVED, TIM TEBOW, NOT
SHAPE OF HIS LIFE. HE SOMEHOW
ONLY IS HE IN THE GREATEST
TRANSFORMED HIS NATURAL
SHAPE OF HIS LIFE. HE SOMEHOW
SKILLS BEYOND A POINT THAT
TRANSFORMED HIS NATURAL
ANYONE EVER WOULD HAVE
SKILLS BEYOND A POINT THAT
EXPECTED AND IF WE DON'T
ANYONE EVER WOULD HAVE
SIGN HIM, SOMEONE ELSE IS
EXPECTED AND IF WE DON'T
GOING TO FIGURE IT OUT AND
SIGN HIM, SOMEONE ELSE IS
THEY'RE GOING TO GET HIM ON
GOING TO FIGURE IT OUT AND
THE TEAM. WE HAVE A POTENTIAL
THEY'RE GOING TO GET HIM ON
TO HAVE A SECRET WEAPON HERE.
THE TEAM. WE HAVE A POTENTIAL
IT'S WE'RE COUNTY COMMON
TO HAVE A SECRET WEAPON HERE.
SENSE, LOGIC, AND WORKOUT SAY
IT'S WE'RE COUNTY COMMON
NOTHING WORKOUTS ARE DONE IN
SENSE, LOGIC, AND WORKOUT SAY
THE
NOTHING WORKOUTS ARE DONE IN
NFL JUST
THE
ALL LIKE WAIT, LET'S SEE IF
NFL JUST
THE GUYS HEALTHY. LET'S JUST
ALL LIKE WAIT, LET'S SEE IF
SEE HIM IN PERSON. IT'S NOT
THE GUYS HEALTHY. LET'S JUST
LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
SEE HIM IN PERSON. IT'S NOT
AGAIN THEY'RE GOING TO BE
LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
EVALUATED FOR WHAT THEY'VE
AGAIN THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DONE ON THE FIELD OR WHAT
EVALUATED FOR WHAT THEY'VE
THEY DO ON THE FIELD.
DONE ON THE FIELD OR WHAT
BUT LIKE, IF IT WAS A REAL
THEY DO ON THE FIELD.
TIGHT END, A REAL TIGHT END
BUT LIKE, IF IT WAS A REAL
AGAIN, THERE HAVE GOING TO
TIGHT END, A REAL TIGHT END
HAVE WATCHED HIM ON FILM. NOW
AGAIN, THERE HAVE GOING TO
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A
HAVE WATCHED HIM ON FILM. NOW
WORKOUT ONLY JUST TO GO. HEY,
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LET'S SEE HIM RUN AND CATCH,
WORKOUT ONLY JUST TO GO. HEY,
MAKE SURE HE'S HEALTHY, SEE
LET'S SEE HIM RUN AND CATCH,
EVERYTHING HE CAN DO
MAKE SURE HE'S HEALTHY, SEE
EVERYTHING PHYSICALLY. THAT'S
EVERYTHING HE CAN DO
IT. YOU'RE NOT GOING LIKE OH,
EVERYTHING PHYSICALLY. THAT'S
HE REALLY IMPROVED. OH,
IT. YOU'RE NOT GOING LIKE OH,
HE'S COMING OUT OF BRAKES,
HE REALLY IMPROVED. OH,
FULL SPEED, MAN. LOOK AT THAT.
HE'S COMING OUT OF BRAKES,
SWIM SWIM MOVE AGAINST
FULL SPEED, MAN. LOOK AT THAT.
IMAGINARY. NO ONE IN FRONT OF
SWIM SWIM MOVE AGAINST
HIM IN THIS WORKOUT. LIKE NO,
IMAGINARY. NO ONE IN FRONT OF
THAT'S NOT WHAT A WORKOUTS
HIM IN THIS WORKOUT. LIKE NO,
ABOUT THEIR. HE COULDN'T
THAT'S NOT WHAT A WORKOUTS
HAVE PROVED TO ANYBODY TO THE
ABOUT THEIR. HE COULDN'T
POINT TO LIKE DURING A
HAVE PROVED TO ANYBODY TO THE
WORKOUT THAT IT'S ALL HE CAN
POINT TO LIKE DURING A
DO IT, HE CAN PLAY TIGHT END.
WORKOUT THAT IT'S ALL HE CAN
LOOK HE COLLAPSED THE RIGHT
DO IT, HE CAN PLAY TIGHT END.
SIDE OF THE LINE ON THAT RUN
LOOK HE COLLAPSED THE RIGHT
PLAY. AND THEN THE NEXT PLAY
SIDE OF THE LINE ON THAT RUN
GOT OPEN AGAIN, SMILES. JACK
PLAY. AND THEN THE NEXT PLAY
HE'S READY. NO, COME ON, STOP
GOT OPEN AGAIN, SMILES. JACK
SO I DON'T NEED TO KNOW
HE'S READY. NO, COME ON, STOP
JOSHUA BELL. I KNOW IT WASN'T
SO I DON'T NEED TO KNOW
SO GREAT.
JOSHUA BELL. I KNOW IT WASN'T
THAT HE NEEDS TO BE SIGNED ON
SO GREAT.
NFL FOOTBALL TEAM. I'M SORRY
THAT HE NEEDS TO BE SIGNED ON
THAT MAYBE THAT'S NOT THE
NFL FOOTBALL TEAM. I'M SORRY
BEST DANCER IN THE WORLD, BUT
THAT MAYBE THAT'S NOT THE
IT'S COLIN. BAIRD SAYS WHO'S
BEST DANCER IN THE WORLD, BUT
REPS. IS HE STEALING? WHO'S
IT'S COLIN. BAIRD SAYS WHO'S
IN THE JAGUARS TIGHT END ROOM
REPS. IS HE STEALING? WHO'S
RIGHT NOW? THAT, THAT IS TIED
IN THE JAGUARS TIGHT END ROOM
TO THIS NARRATIVE OF, HEY,
RIGHT NOW? THAT, THAT IS TIED
THEY THEY HAVE NO ONE AT THE
TO THIS NARRATIVE OF, HEY,
POSITION. THEY NEED THE HELP.
THEY THEY HAVE NO ONE AT THE
WELL, OKAY, THE EASY ANSWER
POSITION. THEY NEED THE HELP.
TO THAT IS THERE ARE
WELL, OKAY, THE EASY ANSWER
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS OUT
TO THAT IS THERE ARE
THERE WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS OUT
JOBS, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
THERE WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
HAVE PLAYED TIGHT END IN THE
JOBS, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
NFL. YES, VERY MUCH LIKE TO
HAVE PLAYED TIGHT END IN THE
CONTINUE THEIR CAREERS,
NFL. YES, VERY MUCH LIKE TO
NO SHORTAGE OF TIGHT ENDS,
CONTINUE THEIR CAREERS,
THERE'S THERE'S NO TIGHT END
NO SHORTAGE OF TIGHT ENDS,
PIPELINE THAT'S BEEN HACKED
THERE'S THERE'S NO TIGHT END
AND SHUT DOWN BY THE RUSSIANS
PIPELINE THAT'S BEEN HACKED
THAT THERE ARE TIGHT ENDS
AND SHUT DOWN BY THE RUSSIANS
GALORE IF YOU WANT A TIGHT
THAT THERE ARE TIGHT ENDS
END. IT'S YEAH, YOU, YOU'RE
GALORE IF YOU WANT A TIGHT
NOT HAPPY WITH THE TIGHT END.
END. IT'S YEAH, YOU, YOU'RE
IT'S YEAH, YOU YOU'RE NOT
NOT HAPPY WITH THE TIGHT END.
HAPPY WITH THE TIGHT END. YOU
IT'S YEAH, YOU YOU'RE NOT
HAVE YOU GO FIND ONE OF THE
HAPPY WITH THE TIGHT END. YOU
ONES FROM THE QUALIFIED GROUP
HAVE YOU GO FIND ONE OF THE
OF TIGHT ENDS, WHO ARE OUT
ONES FROM THE QUALIFIED GROUP
THERE THAT YOU CAN BRING IN
OF TIGHT ENDS, WHO ARE OUT
AND WORK OUT AND PUT ON YOUR
THERE THAT YOU CAN BRING IN
TEAM WHO HAVE PLAYED THE
AND WORK OUT AND PUT ON YOUR
POSITION AT SOME RESPECTABLE
TEAM WHO HAVE PLAYED THE
LEVEL AND HAVE SHOWN, THEY
POSITION AT SOME RESPECTABLE
CAN DO IT, THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
LEVEL AND HAVE SHOWN, THEY
YOU DON'T GO, YOU DON'T GO,
CAN DO IT, THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
ROUTINE TO BRING INTO PLAY
YOU DON'T GO, YOU DON'T GO,
TIGHT END. THAT'S THE EASY
ROUTINE TO BRING INTO PLAY
ANSWER TO THAT ONE. YEAH,
TIGHT END. THAT'S THE EASY
I MEAN YOU SAID IT RIGHT?
ANSWER TO THAT ONE. YEAH,
EXACTLY. YOU KNOW WHO'S
I MEAN YOU SAID IT RIGHT?
REPS? IS HE STEALING? YEAH,
EXACTLY. YOU KNOW WHO'S
OF THE GUYS THAT WE DON'T
REPS? IS HE STEALING? YEAH,
KNOW THEIR NAMES ARE, DO KNOW
OF THE GUYS THAT WE DON'T
A LOT ABOUT THEM BUT THEY ARE
KNOW THEIR NAMES ARE, DO KNOW
TIGHT ENDS IN THE NFL. HE'S
A LOT ABOUT THEM BUT THEY ARE
STEALING THEIR REPS AND THEIR
TIGHT ENDS IN THE NFL. HE'S
ABILITY TO GET BETTER THAT
STEALING THEIR REPS AND THEIR
WAY. AND THEN, LIKE, WHO'S IN
ABILITY TO GET BETTER THAT
THE JAGUARS TIGHT END RIGHT
WAY. AND THEN, LIKE, WHO'S IN
NOW? I MEAN, AGAIN, IT'S NOT
THE JAGUARS TIGHT END RIGHT
A STRONG GROUP. I UNDERSTAND
NOW? I MEAN, AGAIN, IT'S NOT
THAT TIM TEBOW DOESN'T MAKE
A STRONG GROUP. I UNDERSTAND
STRONGER. WHAT? LIKE GET THE
THAT TIM TEBOW DOESN'T MAKE
HELL OUT OF HERE.
STRONGER. WHAT? LIKE GET THE
I MEAN, IT'S ALWAYS WHEN YOU
HELL OUT OF HERE.
SAY IT OUT LOUD, IT ALMOST
I MEAN, IT'S ALWAYS WHEN YOU
MAKES IT SOUND LIKE IT'S
SAY IT OUT LOUD, IT ALMOST
WEAKER. LIKE, THAT DOESN'T
MAKES IT SOUND LIKE IT'S
MAKE SENSE. YOU DIDN'T MAKE
WEAKER. LIKE, THAT DOESN'T
THE ROOM BETTER THAT WAY.
MAKE SENSE. YOU DIDN'T MAKE
IT'S NOT LIKE UH, WE GOT TIM
THE ROOM BETTER THAT WAY.
IN HERE NOW GUYS. THE TIGHT
IT'S NOT LIKE UH, WE GOT TIM
END ROOMS COMPLETE. WE'RE
IN HERE NOW GUYS. THE TIGHT
GOOD GUYS, WE'RE GOOD. WE'RE
END ROOMS COMPLETE. WE'RE
NOT LOOKING FOR FREE AGENTS.
GOOD GUYS, WE'RE GOOD. WE'RE
ANY MORE LIKE, GET OUT OF
NOT LOOKING FOR FREE AGENTS.
HERE? WELL, WELL, THAT MEANS
ANY MORE LIKE, GET OUT OF
NOTHING AND HE DOES NOT
HERE? WELL, WELL, THAT MEANS
IMPROVE THE TIGHT END ROOM
NOTHING AND HE DOES NOT
AND ALL THE THINGS YOU SAID
IMPROVE THE TIGHT END ROOM
ARE REALLY SPOT-ON.
AND ALL THE THINGS YOU SAID
ANOTHER ONE. HE CAN BE THE
ARE REALLY SPOT-ON.
JAGUARS VERSION OF TASTE. OH
ANOTHER ONE. HE CAN BE THE
MY GOD. GET THE HELL BACK.
JAGUARS VERSION OF TASTE. OH
PEOPLE THOUGHT TAYSOM HILL
MY GOD. GET THE HELL BACK.
WAS A WASTE OF A ROSTER SPOT
PEOPLE THOUGHT TAYSOM HILL
AS WELL. HE RAN A 4/5. YEAH.
WAS A WASTE OF A ROSTER SPOT
THEY WERE 4 FOR 4 AT HIS PRO
AS WELL. HE RAN A 4/5. YEAH.
DAY. RAN FOR FOUR, FOR EVEN
THEY WERE 4 FOR 4 AT HIS PRO
BETTER, WRITE FASTER, RIGHT?
DAY. RAN FOR FOUR, FOR EVEN
AND LIKE MEAN LEGIT EXPLOSION
BETTER, WRITE FASTER, RIGHT?
AND LET'S NOT FORGET TAYSOM
AND LIKE MEAN LEGIT EXPLOSION
HILL, LIKE, LEGIT ARM. THIS
AND LET'S NOT FORGET TAYSOM
IS NOT LIKE TIM TEBOW WHERE
HILL, LIKE, LEGIT ARM. THIS
WE JUST THROW FLUTTERING
IS NOT LIKE TIM TEBOW WHERE
DUCKS IN THE AIR QUARTERBACK
WE JUST THROW FLUTTERING
EITHER. SO NO, IT'S NOT THE
DUCKS IN THE AIR QUARTERBACK
SAME AND I HEAR. I SEE HER
EITHER. SO NO, IT'S NOT THE
PEOPLE. WE GOT ONE HERE RIGHT
SAME AND I HEAR. I SEE HER
AT SPA GE. HE COULD ALSO
PEOPLE. WE GOT ONE HERE RIGHT
PLAY THE TASTE OF HE'LL ROLL.
AT SPA GE. HE COULD ALSO
HE'S AN INCREDIBLE ATHLETE.
PLAY THE TASTE OF HE'LL ROLL.
HE'S NOT THE SAME ATHLETE, IS
HE'S AN INCREDIBLE ATHLETE.
TAYSOM HILL TAKES THEM A THAT.
HE'S NOT THE SAME ATHLETE, IS
CAN BEAT ALVIN KAMARA IN A
TAYSOM HILL TAKES THEM A THAT.
RACE. TIM TEBOW CANNOT,
CAN BEAT ALVIN KAMARA IN A
THAT'S INSANE. AND IF YOU
RACE. TIM TEBOW CANNOT,
WANT TO RUN THAT OFFENSE,
THAT'S INSANE. AND IF YOU
THAT YOU HAVE TWO RUNNING
WANT TO RUN THAT OFFENSE,
BACKS, PUT TRAVIS ETIENNE AT
THAT YOU HAVE TWO RUNNING
QUARTERBACK AND LET HIM RUN
BACKS, PUT TRAVIS ETIENNE AT
THE BALL AND JAMES ROBINSON
QUARTERBACK AND LET HIM RUN
GOING TO BE NEXT TO HIM
THE BALL AND JAMES ROBINSON
RUNNING THE BALL. SO THAT'S
GOING TO BE NEXT TO HIM
THAT'S NOT AN OPTION EITHER.
RUNNING THE BALL. SO THAT'S
LIKE
THAT'S NOT AN OPTION EITHER.
THAT WOULD NOT BE A REALISTIC
LIKE
THING FOR ANYONE CREDIBLE IN
THAT WOULD NOT BE A REALISTIC
THE NFL TO BE THINKING ABOUT.
THING FOR ANYONE CREDIBLE IN
LET ME GET THE GUY WHO HASN'T
THE NFL TO BE THINKING ABOUT.
PLAYED EIGHT YEARS, WASN'T
LET ME GET THE GUY WHO HASN'T
REALLY THAT FAST TO BEGIN
PLAYED EIGHT YEARS, WASN'T
WITH, BUT NOW, HEY, I'M GOING
REALLY THAT FAST TO BEGIN
TO GIVE HIM SOME REPS, A
WITH, BUT NOW, HEY, I'M GOING
QUARTERBACK AND WE DRAFTED
TO GIVE HIM SOME REPS, A
THE NUMBER ONE QUARTERBACK
QUARTERBACK AND WE DRAFTED
IN THE DRAFT, BUT WE'RE
THE NUMBER ONE QUARTERBACK
GOING TO PUT HIM ON THE BENCH
IN THE DRAFT, BUT WE'RE
FOR A FEW PLAYS. SO TEBOW CAN
GOING TO PUT HIM ON THE BENCH
RUN BEHIND THE PULLING GUARD.
FOR A FEW PLAYS. SO TEBOW CAN
OKAY, GET THE HELL OUT OF
RUN BEHIND THE PULLING GUARD.
HERE. PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR
OKAY, GET THE HELL OUT OF
DAMN MINDS OVER THIS AND LET
HERE. PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR
TELL YOU QUICK TASTY MEALS
DAMN MINDS OVER THIS AND LET
STORE JUST TO ILLUSTRATE.
TELL YOU QUICK TASTY MEALS
WAIT, THE ATHLETICISM THAT HE
STORE JUST TO ILLUSTRATE.
POSSESSED RIGHT BACK BEFORE.
WAIT, THE ATHLETICISM THAT HE
ANYONE KNEW ABOUT TAYSOM HILL
POSSESSED RIGHT BACK BEFORE.
AND HE WAS JUST A SPECIAL
ANYONE KNEW ABOUT TAYSOM HILL
TEAMER ON THE SAINTS AND HE
AND HE WAS JUST A SPECIAL
WAS RUNNING DOWN ON KICK
TEAMER ON THE SAINTS AND HE
COVERAGE, PUNT COVERAGE,
WAS RUNNING DOWN ON KICK
WHATEVER I THINK WAS
COVERAGE, PUNT COVERAGE,
PRIMARILY KICKOFF COVERAGE
WHATEVER I THINK WAS
WHEN YOU GOTTA RUN DOWN THE
PRIMARILY KICKOFF COVERAGE
FIELD, HE WAS SO FAST. IT
WHEN YOU GOTTA RUN DOWN THE
MADE THE OTHER GUYS LOOK SLOW,
FIELD, HE WAS SO FAST. IT
AND THEY'D GET CALLED OUT IN
MADE THE OTHER GUYS LOOK SLOW,
THE FRONT ROOM FOR NOT
AND THEY'D GET CALLED OUT IN
BUSTING THEIR ASSES DOWN THE
THE FRONT ROOM FOR NOT
FIELD BECAUSE HE'LL WAS SO
BUSTING THEIR ASSES DOWN THE
MUCH FASTER THAN EVERYONE
FIELD BECAUSE HE'LL WAS SO
ELSE, AND IT POPPED ON FILM
MUCH FASTER THAN EVERYONE
THAT. HEY GUYS. HEY GUYS,
ELSE, AND IT POPPED ON FILM
COME ON, GET THE LEAD OUT.
THAT. HEY GUYS. HEY GUYS,
NO, WE COULD TASTE THEM DOWN
COME ON, GET THE LEAD OUT.
THERE. WHERE ARE YOU? IT'S
NO, WE COULD TASTE THEM DOWN
LIKE, YEAH, BECAUSE HE IS
THERE. WHERE ARE YOU? IT'S
FASTER THAN ALMOST EVERYBODY
LIKE, YEAH, BECAUSE HE IS
IN THE BUILDING. AND THAT'S
FASTER THAN ALMOST EVERYBODY
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TAYSOM
IN THE BUILDING. AND THAT'S
HILL AND TIM TEBOW. TAYSOM
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TAYSOM
HILL IS A LEGITIMATE NFL
HILL AND TIM TEBOW. TAYSOM
COMPETITOR. TIM TEBOW AT THIS
HILL IS A LEGITIMATE NFL
POINT, IS A GIMMICK PERIOD.
COMPETITOR. TIM TEBOW AT THIS
YEAH. HERE'S ANOTHER ONE. AND
POINT, IS A GIMMICK PERIOD.
THIS ONE HAS I THINK A LITTLE
YEAH. HERE'S ANOTHER ONE. AND
MORE TO UNPACK THAN THE BASIC
THIS ONE HAS I THINK A LITTLE
KNEE JERK? HEY, YOU'RE JUST
MORE TO UNPACK THAN THE BASIC
WRONG. THE IDEA THAT THIS IS
KNEE JERK? HEY, YOU'RE JUST
LIKE TAKING A BASKETBALL
WRONG. THE IDEA THAT THIS IS
PLAYER.
LIKE TAKING A BASKETBALL
WHO'S NEVER PLAYED IN THE NFL,
PLAYER.
NEVER PLAYED FOOTBALL AND
WHO'S NEVER PLAYED IN THE NFL,
YOU KNOW ANTONIOU GATES AT
NEVER PLAYED FOOTBALL AND
JIMMY GRAHAM. THIS IS A GUY
YOU KNOW ANTONIOU GATES AT
WHO'S A PROJECT. WE'RE GOING
JIMMY GRAHAM. THIS IS A GUY
MAKE HIM A TIGHT END. BRIAN
WHO'S A PROJECT. WE'RE GOING
WILDER POINTED THIS OUT ON
MAKE HIM A TIGHT END. BRIAN
TWITTER. MIAMI, JUST SIGNED A
WILDER POINTED THIS OUT ON
KID, WHO'S NEVER PLAYED
TWITTER. MIAMI, JUST SIGNED A
FOOTBALL AS A TIGHT END. HE
KID, WHO'S NEVER PLAYED
PLAYED BASKETBALL ONLY,
FOOTBALL AS A TIGHT END. HE
THAT'S JIBBERY, BLUNT FROM
PLAYED BASKETBALL ONLY,
NORTH CAROLINA, CENTRAL, THE
THAT'S JIBBERY, BLUNT FROM
SON OF OF HALL OF FAMER, MEL
NORTH CAROLINA, CENTRAL, THE
BLOUNT. BUT THAT'S A CLEAR
SON OF OF HALL OF FAMER, MEL
PROJECT THAT'S NOT A GIMMICK.
BLOUNT. BUT THAT'S A CLEAR
THAT IS A, WE'RE TAKING A GUY
PROJECT THAT'S NOT A GIMMICK.
GIMMICK. THAT IS A, WE'RE
THAT IS A, WE'RE TAKING A GUY
TAKING A GUY WHO WAS A LUMP
GIMMICK. THAT IS A, WE'RE
OF THE PERFECT TIGHT END
TAKING A GUY WHO WAS A LUMP
ALREADY AND IT HAS ALL THE
OF THE PERFECT TIGHT END
ALREADY SEEN NFL'S IN THE NFL
ALREADY AND IT HAS ALL THE
TIGHT ENDS. HAVE THESE
ALREADY SEEN NFL'S IN THE NFL
MEASURABLES IN THIS SIZE AND
TIGHT ENDS. HAVE THESE
IT TRANSLATES TO GREATNESS
MEASURABLES IN THIS SIZE AND
NOT EX QUARTERBACKS WHO ARE
IT TRANSLATES TO GREATNESS
6-1 220-POUND, BUT GO AHEAD,
NOT EX QUARTERBACKS WHO ARE
GOING. YEAH, NO, NOT THAT MY
6-1 220-POUND, BUT GO AHEAD,
POINT BUT THIS IS NOT A LUMP
GOING. YEAH, NO, NOT THAT MY
OF CLAY. THIS IS A BROKEN
POINT BUT THIS IS NOT A LUMP
CRACKED DRIED OUT BOWL THAT
OF CLAY. THIS IS A BROKEN
DID ALREADY. THE CLAY WAS
CRACKED DRIED OUT BOWL THAT
TURNED INTO SOMETHING AND IT
DID ALREADY. THE CLAY WAS
DIDN'T WORK. AND LIKE YOU
TURNED INTO SOMETHING AND IT
SAID HE HAD HIS CHANCE,
DIDN'T WORK. AND LIKE YOU
EIGHT, NINE YEARS AGO TO
SAID HE HAD HIS CHANCE,
BECOME A TIGHT END AND HE
EIGHT, NINE YEARS AGO TO
SAID, HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT
BECOME A TIGHT END AND HE
RIGHT? AND HE, AND HE LEFT
SAID, HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT
THE SPORT, AND THAT'S THAT.
RIGHT? AND HE, AND HE LEFT
SO THIS
THE SPORT, AND THAT'S THAT.
IS FAR DIFFERENT THAN THEN,
SO THIS
YOU KNOW, PANNING FOR GOLD OR
IS FAR DIFFERENT THAN THEN,
LOOKING FOR A NEEDLE IN A
YOU KNOW, PANNING FOR GOLD OR
HAYSTACK, AND FINDING THE
LOOKING FOR A NEEDLE IN A
RIGHT BUILD, THE RIGHT FRAME,
HAYSTACK, AND FINDING THE
THE RIGHT GUY, WHO CAN COME
RIGHT BUILD, THE RIGHT FRAME,
IN AND YOU CAN YOU CAN ALMOST
THE RIGHT GUY, WHO CAN COME
MANUFACTURER IN A LABORATORY
IN AND YOU CAN YOU CAN ALMOST
INTO A PERFECT NFL TIGHT END
MANUFACTURER IN A LABORATORY
FAR DIFFERENT THAN THAT. BUT
INTO A PERFECT NFL TIGHT END
YES. COULD YOU IS JIBBERY
FAR DIFFERENT THAN THAT. BUT
BLUNT READY TO WALK IN AND
YES. COULD YOU IS JIBBERY
PLAY TIGHT END IN THE NFL
BLUNT READY TO WALK IN AND
RIGHT NOW? NO, BUT THERE'S A
PLAY TIGHT END IN THE NFL
CEILING FOR HIM THAT JUST
RIGHT NOW? NO, BUT THERE'S A
ISN'T THERE FOR TIM TEBOW.
CEILING FOR HIM THAT JUST
KNOW, EXACTLY, RIGHT. I MEAN,
ISN'T THERE FOR TIM TEBOW.
TO GET A GUY LIKE, AND
KNOW, EXACTLY, RIGHT. I MEAN,
ANTONIO GATES, OR A TONY
TO GET A GUY LIKE, AND
GONZALEZ, OR SOME OF THE
ANTONIO GATES, OR A TONY
OTHER STORIES. WE'VE HEARD
GONZALEZ, OR SOME OF THE
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, JIMMY GRAHAM,
OTHER STORIES. WE'VE HEARD
RIGHT? IT'S THOSE KIND OF
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, JIMMY GRAHAM,
THOSE GUYS ARE FREAKS OF
RIGHT? IT'S THOSE KIND OF
NATURE FIRST OFF, AND THIS
THOSE GUYS ARE FREAKS OF
GUY JABARI BLUNT HAS SOME OF
NATURE FIRST OFF, AND THIS
THOSE SKILLS TO. THAT'S WHY
GUY JABARI BLUNT HAS SOME OF
HE'S BEEN GIVING THAT SHOT.
THOSE SKILLS TO. THAT'S WHY
IT'S LIKE, HEY, HE'S UP, HE'S
HE'S BEEN GIVING THAT SHOT.
GOT, YOU KNOW, SOME SIGHS, WE
IT'S LIKE, HEY, HE'S UP, HE'S
LIKE THAT MAKES SENSE FOR THE
GOT, YOU KNOW, SOME SIGHS, WE
POSITION AND THEN HE HAS
LIKE THAT MAKES SENSE FOR THE
SOME PHYSICAL THINGS. HE DOES.
POSITION AND THEN HE HAS
THAT ARE LIKE REALLY SPECIAL.
SOME PHYSICAL THINGS. HE DOES.
SO
THAT ARE LIKE REALLY SPECIAL.
SO LET'S SEE IF WE CAN WORK
SO
WITH HIM. NONE OF THAT IS,
SO LET'S SEE IF WE CAN WORK
THAT'S NOT A PART OF THE
WITH HIM. NONE OF THAT IS,
CONVERSATION WITH TEBOW. YEAH,
THAT'S NOT A PART OF THE
I KNOW. HE'S GOING TO WORK
CONVERSATION WITH TEBOW. YEAH,
HARD AND DO ALL THOSE THINGS,
I KNOW. HE'S GOING TO WORK
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE OTHER
HARD AND DO ALL THOSE THINGS,
THING TOO. YOU HEAR MIC LIKE,
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE OTHER
WELL, HE MIGHT HELP THE
THING TOO. YOU HEAR MIC LIKE,
CULTURE DOWN THERE, WHAT?
WELL, HE MIGHT HELP THE
LIKE CRAZY FIRST OFF. YOU
CULTURE DOWN THERE, WHAT?
DON'T WANT TIM TEBOW FRAMING
LIKE CRAZY FIRST OFF. YOU
YOUR CULTURE, REALLY? YOU
DON'T WANT TIM TEBOW FRAMING
DON'T YOU'D LIKE TREVOR
YOUR CULTURE, REALLY? YOU
LAWRENCE AND SOME OF THE
DON'T YOU'D LIKE TREVOR
OTHER LEADERS TO TAKE
LAWRENCE AND SOME OF THE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND TO LIKE
OTHER LEADERS TO TAKE
TO SAY HOW SILLY THAT IS
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND TO LIKE
PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO LIKE
TO SAY HOW SILLY THAT IS
TO SAY HOW SILLY THAT IS,
PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO LIKE
TIM TEBOW, R9 TIGHT END ON
TO SAY HOW SILLY THAT IS,
THE ROSTERS OUT HERE CATCHING
TIM TEBOW, R9 TIGHT END ON
A FEW EXTRA BALLS. LET ME
THE ROSTERS OUT HERE CATCHING
STAY OUT HERE AND WORK TO
A FEW EXTRA BALLS. LET ME
LIKE COME ON. THAT'S NOT THE
STAY OUT HERE AND WORK TO
KIND OF GUY OR STORY THEY
LIKE COME ON. THAT'S NOT THE
FOLLOW HERE. THAT'S THIS IS
KIND OF GUY OR STORY THEY
FAIRY TALE LAND. SOME OF THIS
FOLLOW HERE. THAT'S THIS IS
STUFF PEOPLE ARE TALKING
FAIRY TALE LAND. SOME OF THIS
ABOUT RIGHT NOW THINK ABOUT
STUFF PEOPLE ARE TALKING
THIS TO THE DAY THAT THE
ABOUT RIGHT NOW THINK ABOUT
DRAFT WAS DUE TO BEGIN THE
THIS TO THE DAY THAT THE
DAY. THAT TREVOR LAWRENCE WAS
DRAFT WAS DUE TO BEGIN THE
GOING TO HEAR HIS NAME CALLED
DAY. THAT TREVOR LAWRENCE WAS
TO CAP A PROCESS WHERE HE
GOING TO HEAR HIS NAME CALLED
HAD TAKEN A BACKSEAT TO
TO CAP A PROCESS WHERE HE
TRAIL, AN SMACK JONES,
HAD TAKEN A BACKSEAT TO
NOBODY WAS PAYING ATTENTION.
TRAIL, AN SMACK JONES,
CARED BECAUSE EVERYBODY KNEW
NOBODY WAS PAYING ATTENTION.
IT WAS PREORDAINED. LANCE,
CARED BECAUSE EVERYBODY KNEW
TREVOR LAWRENCE WAS THE GUY
IT WAS PREORDAINED. LANCE,
AND THEN JUST HOURS BEFORE
TREVOR LAWRENCE WAS THE GUY
THE PROCESS BEGINS, THEY
AND THEN JUST HOURS BEFORE
LEAKED TO NFL MEDIA THAT THEY
THE PROCESS BEGINS, THEY
MAY BE SIGNING TIM. TEBOW, IF
LEAKED TO NFL MEDIA THAT THEY
YOU'RE TREVOR LAWRENCE,
MAY BE SIGNING TIM. TEBOW, IF
YOU'RE LIKE, WHAT THE HELL?
YOU'RE TREVOR LAWRENCE,
YEAH, I'M THE NEW FACE OF THE
YOU'RE LIKE, WHAT THE HELL?
FRANCHISE. I'M THE NUMBER ONE
YEAH, I'M THE NEW FACE OF THE
OVERALL PICK IN THE DRAFT.
FRANCHISE. I'M THE NUMBER ONE
WHAT THE HELL'S TIM TEBOW
OVERALL PICK IN THE DRAFT.
HAVE TO DO WITH ANYTHING? SO
WHAT THE HELL'S TIM TEBOW
YOU KNOW, YOU WANT TO CHANGE
HAVE TO DO WITH ANYTHING? SO
THE CULTURE, YOU MAKE HIM AN
YOU KNOW, YOU WANT TO CHANGE
ASSISTANT COACH, YOU'LL FIND
THE CULTURE, YOU MAKE HIM AN
A JOB FOR HIM. SO HE'S IN THE
ASSISTANT COACH, YOU'LL FIND
BUILDING YOUR WEDGE HIM ONTO
A JOB FOR HIM. SO HE'S IN THE
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CHART
BUILDING YOUR WEDGE HIM ONTO
BECAUSE HE HAS VALUE TO YOUR
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CHART
TEAM. YOU DON'T GIVE THEM A
BECAUSE HE HAS VALUE TO YOUR
ROSTER SPOT WITH AN EYE
TEAM. YOU DON'T GIVE THEM A
TOWARD GIVING HIM ONE OF THE
ROSTER SPOT WITH AN EYE
53 ROSTER SPOTS ARE FINDING A
TOWARD GIVING HIM ONE OF THE
WAY TO FORCE HIM ONTO THE
53 ROSTER SPOTS ARE FINDING A
FIELD, JUST TO PROVE THAT YOU
WAY TO FORCE HIM ONTO THE
WERE RIGHT BECAUSE BECAUSE
FIELD, JUST TO PROVE THAT YOU
HERE'S WHAT WILL HAPPEN,
WERE RIGHT BECAUSE BECAUSE
THEY'LL COME UP WITH SOME
HERE'S WHAT WILL HAPPEN,
PLAY CHRISTY YOU ARE I COULD
THEY'LL COME UP WITH SOME
HAVE RUN AND CAUGHT A
PLAY CHRISTY YOU ARE I COULD
TOUCHDOWN PASS FROM THE
HAVE RUN AND CAUGHT A
3-YARD LINE, THEY'LL COME UP
TOUCHDOWN PASS FROM THE
WITH SOMETHING. YOU KNOW,
3-YARD LINE, THEY'LL COME UP
THAT THAT'S THE STANDARD
WITH SOMETHING. YOU KNOW,
TRICK PLAY. THAT POPS. SO AN
THAT THAT'S THE STANDARD
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN OPEN FOR A
TRICK PLAY. THAT POPS. SO AN
ONE, WE ALMOST SAW IN THE
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN OPEN FOR A
SUPER BOWL, THEY'LL DO
ONE, WE ALMOST SAW IN THE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. AND
SUPER BOWL, THEY'LL DO
THAT'LL BE VINDICATION FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. AND
URBAN MEYER. NO, NO. IT'S
THAT'LL BE VINDICATION FOR
IT WON'T BE BUT BUT I
URBAN MEYER. NO, NO. IT'S
GUARANTEE YOU WE'RE GOING TO
IT WON'T BE BUT BUT I
SEE HIM IN UNIFORM AND WE'RE
GUARANTEE YOU WE'RE GOING TO
GOING TO SEE HIM PLAY. IF
SEE HIM IN UNIFORM AND WE'RE
THEY SIGN THEM, IF THEY SIGN,
GOING TO SEE HIM PLAY. IF
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THIS IS
THEY SIGN THEM, IF THEY SIGN,
THE BYPRODUCT OF THE CHRIS
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THIS IS
DOYLE SITUATION WHERE THEY
THE BYPRODUCT OF THE CHRIS
HIRED HIM, THEY GOT THE
DOYLE SITUATION WHERE THEY
BLOWBACK AND THEY HAD TO MOVE
HIRED HIM, THEY GOT THE
ON FROM HIM. IT MAY BE THAT
BLOWBACK AND THEY HAD TO MOVE
THEY'RE THEY'RE MAKING SURE A,
ON FROM HIM. IT MAY BE THAT
YOU KNOW, SPEAK NOW OR
THEY'RE THEY'RE MAKING SURE A,
FOREVER, HOLD YOUR PEACE.
YOU KNOW, SPEAK NOW OR
YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO SIGN TIM
FOREVER, HOLD YOUR PEACE.
TEBOW. WE'RE GOING
YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO SIGN TIM
AND TIM TEBOW JUST TO FLESH
TEBOW. WE'RE GOING
OUT, DO IT. YEAH, I MEAN, IT
AND TIM TEBOW JUST TO FLESH
MAY BE, YOU KNOW, MAYBE THEY
OUT, DO IT. YEAH, I MEAN, IT
ARE JUST GAUGING THIS GAUGING,
MAY BE, YOU KNOW, MAYBE THEY
TEMPERATURE AROUND THIS
ARE JUST GAUGING THIS GAUGING,
CONVERSATION AND ALL THAT,
TEMPERATURE AROUND THIS
BUT LISTEN WE ROASTED ROGERS
CONVERSATION AND ALL THAT,
EVERYBODY DID FOR HIJACKING
BUT LISTEN WE ROASTED ROGERS
THE DRAFT TIM TEBOW TRIED TO
EVERYBODY DID FOR HIJACKING
DO THE SAME TYPE OF THING. I
THE DRAFT TIM TEBOW TRIED TO
DON'T KNOW WHO REPRESENTS HIM
DO THE SAME TYPE OF THING. I
RIGHT NOW PROBABLY. I THINK
DON'T KNOW WHO REPRESENTS HIM
IT'S CAA WHATEVER IT IS BUT
RIGHT NOW PROBABLY. I THINK
THAT WAS A PLANNED ATTACK. HE
IT'S CAA WHATEVER IT IS BUT
WASN'T SIGNED BY A TEAM.
THAT WAS A PLANNED ATTACK. HE
NOTHING HAD HAPPENED. YES,
WASN'T SIGNED BY A TEAM.
THEY HAD OBVIOUSLY
NOTHING HAD HAPPENED. YES,
REACHED OUT TO URBAN, THEY
THEY HAD OBVIOUSLY
RELEASED THAT INFORMATION TO
REACHED OUT TO URBAN, THEY
BEFORE THE DRAFT. I MEAN,
RELEASED THAT INFORMATION TO
JACKSONVILLE DIDN'T THEY
BEFORE THE DRAFT. I MEAN,
WEREN'T LIKE HEY THIS IS OUR
JACKSONVILLE DIDN'T THEY
BIG NIGHT SAID ONE OF THE
WEREN'T LIKE HEY THIS IS OUR
BIGGEST DRAFTS OF OUR
BIG NIGHT SAID ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATION'S HISTORY. HEY,
BIGGEST DRAFTS OF OUR
LET'S LET'S PUT OUT THAT
ORGANIZATION'S HISTORY. HEY,
T-BONE NUGGET AND GET
LET'S LET'S PUT OUT THAT
EVERYBODY GO. LIKE I KNOW NO,
T-BONE NUGGET AND GET
THAT WAS RELEASED BY TEBOW.
EVERYBODY GO. LIKE I KNOW NO,
SO LIKE AGAIN, IF WE'RE
THAT WAS RELEASED BY TEBOW.
GOING TO ROAST ROGERS FOR
SO LIKE AGAIN, IF WE'RE
DOING THAT TYPE OF THING,
GOING TO ROAST ROGERS FOR
THIS IS FAR MORE EGREGIOUS
DOING THAT TYPE OF THING,
AND RIDICULOUS THAT HE DID.
THIS IS FAR MORE EGREGIOUS
IT IT IS MEAN ROGERS HAD A
AND RIDICULOUS THAT HE DID.
POINT TO BE ANGRY AND HAD
IT IT IS MEAN ROGERS HAD A
LIKE SOME
POINT TO BE ANGRY AND HAD
TRUE THINGS IN HIS
LIKE SOME
CORNER TO WHERE HE COULD, YOU
TRUE THINGS IN HIS
COULD JUSTIFY IT. SO THAT'S
CORNER TO WHERE HE COULD, YOU
WHERE I GUESS THE RUBS ME
COULD JUSTIFY IT. SO THAT'S
WRONG, THAT WAY. AND BUT FOR
WHERE I GUESS THE RUBS ME
THE ROGERS THING, IT WOULD
WRONG, THAT WAY. AND BUT FOR
HAVE WORKED. YES, BECAUSE IT
THE ROGERS THING, IT WOULD
JUST MINUTES AFTER THE TEBOW
HAVE WORKED. YES, BECAUSE IT
LEAK. THAT CHEF T DECIDED,
JUST MINUTES AFTER THE TEBOW
NOW WAS THE TIME TO LET THE
LEAK. THAT CHEF T DECIDED,
WORLD KNOW THAT AARON
NOW WAS THE TIME TO LET THE
RODGERS IS DISGRUNTLED KNOWN
WORLD KNOW THAT AARON
ABOUT IT FOR A WHILE. I'M ON
RODGERS IS DISGRUNTLED KNOWN
THEM. REGARDLESS ROGERS,
ABOUT IT FOR A WHILE. I'M ON
WHOEVER WANTED IT OUT. YEAH,
THEM. REGARDLESS ROGERS,
TRUMP TIM TEBOW BEFORE THE
WHOEVER WANTED IT OUT. YEAH,
TIM TEBOW STOR
TRUMP TIM TEBOW BEFORE THE
COFOUF LDTH GE ETGR OUND.